I think I've been a great salesman my
whole life because I don't sell things
that I don't believe in like I believe
that I am going to build one of the most
significant intellectual properties of
all time I really believe that practical
peacock can be like Lisa Simpson one day
as you can imagine that gives me the
energy to go so hard I say to them I'm
like why are you selling something you
don't believe in and I know the answer
people have lives and this is where they
find themselves and they have mortgages
and kids like you know I get it but
there's so many people that could be
doing other things but like what's most
important to me that I believe in it